le contexte dans lequel nous informons
et nous nous divertissons aujourd'hui
est complètement fragmenté qu'il est
mondial qu'il est plurielle en qu'il est
pluri média et donc pluri pays
pour ma part si je devais décrire le
processus qui aboutit aujourd'hui à la
concentration industrielle les médias en
quelques mots auraient quatre points
d'une part la numérisation de
l'information les nouvelles technologies
les nouveaux usages
deuxième point c'est l'environnement
concurrentiel dans lesquels les médias
évoluent aujourd'hui fragmentation des
audiences hyper puissance économique et
financière des nouveaux acteurs qui ont
investi le secteur des médias les
télécoms les gaffes un ou deux
opérateurs qu'on appellera un pur des
pure players qu'elle tels que netflix un
troisième point c'est la façon dont les
français s'informent aujourd'hui
principalement en ligne et sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis en fait un
dernier point qui participe de ce
processus qui serait le modèle
économique des plateformes numériques
qui conduisent à occuper aujourd'hui une
position hégémonique à la fois dans
l'espace informationnel mais aussi dans
l'espace communicationnel et qui
représente un enjeu mocratique j'ai eu
l'occasion de décrire une tribune la
semaine dernière ne sachant pas que
cette audition ait lieu sur justement
l'hégémonie des plateformes numériques
et le danger qu'elles représentent est
alors peut-être en liminaire pour rappel
pour autant le sens que important de
rappeler que les mecs les médias
véhiculent donc à la fois des valeurs
démocratiques de contenu et de sens et
qu'elle génère de nombreuses
externalités positives pour la société
tant de l'accès à la culture à
l'information que le divertissement et
la formation donc on ne peut pas
considérer ce et c'est bien comme des
marchandises comme les autres et que
leur bon fonctionnement peuvent pas se
limiter au seul bon fonctionnement du
marché alors la réglementation actuelle
en tout cas pour le secteur de
l'audiovisuel en matière de
concentration c'est la loi de 84 en
matière d'audiovisuel c'est
effectivement la loi de 86 mais qui a
été modifié plus de 80 100 x 86 x il
s'avère que la dernière modification en
tout cas la dernière révision date du
1er juillet concernait la transposition
de la directive et ses mains pour un
élargissement en fait du du champ de
régulation du conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
en plein au parc en fête les plateformes
de partage de vidéos et les réseaux
sociaux etc actuellement le dispositif
anti-concentration qui s'applique et ne
correspond pas lui n'a pas été modifié
en tout cas il correspond pas
aujourd'hui au secteur me semble-t-il
qui devrait être mis en place puisque
cette loi n'a pas été prise dans son
intention dans son ensemble alors
peut-être le contexte rapidement en
disant que le numérique partout
évidemment mais qu'on a vraiment une
révolution technologique qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui en deux mots 70 % des
téléviseurs seront connectés qu'on est
une révolution économique et j'y
reviendrai et qu'on est une révolution
d'usagé aujourd'hui on a effectivement
temps un nouvel écosystème avec un
concours la possibilité de consommer
quand on veut où on veut et comme on
veut on accède à une offre de contenus
très très large par la tnt l'adsl le
câble à fibre le satellite en direct en
différé un roadie fait en streaming ce
qui fait qu évidemment on a un panel
technologique est possible très ouvert
mais ce qu'il en est c'est comment on
s'informe aujourd'hui puisque la
question quand même derrière la
concentration soit savoir quelle est la
demande me semble-t-il
90% des français qui sont âgés plus de
12 ans déclarent se connecter à internet
tous les jours en plusieurs fois par
semaine 63% des français utilisent
internet pour suivre l'actualité le
permis une personne sur deux est équipé
d'une tablette numérique 73% de la
population et multi équipés et si l'on
regarde les seuls 18 24 ans et près de
deux tiers d'entre eux qui s'informent
uniquement sur internet et les réseaux
sociaux via un smartphone et on voit
bien que youtube que ce soit twitter
snapshot ou encore twitch et plus
récemment aux tic toc ont leur
préférence pour s'informer donc deux
tiers d'entre eux donc on en un mot
suffirait c'est qu'on aimerait garder
réorganisation complète de l'accès à
l'information dans le monde numérique
que les gars failli au puc oui occupe
une position hégémonique à la fois
économiquement et financièrement et
qu'elle impose elle les règles du jeu
démocratique qui me semble pour
comprendre ces règles du jeu faut entrer
cinq minutes si vous me permettez dans
le véritablement la mécanique du modèle
d'affaires que sont les plateformes
parce que finalement c'est véritablement
une dérivée de la façon dont en 1836
emile de girardin avait déjà était déjà
allé dans la création de la gazette
chercher un deuxième financement il
avait déjà mis en évidence que
finalement le fait de mettre un prix
accessible très peu élevé bien permettez
à un plus grand nombre d'individus de
s'informer mais pour autant ce n'est pas
comme ça qu'il arrivait à avoir une
viabilité économique donc c'était déjà
lui au 19e siècle est allé chercher une
seconde source de financement qui est le
financement de la publicité et donc
jusqu'à ce que finalement on a une
possibilité aujourd'hui d'avoir accès à
des journaux que ce soit en papier que
télévision ou radio gratuitement pour
nous et on pourrait presque dire que
c'est subventionnés par les annonceurs
cette mécanique est la 2 par
l'industrialisation des médias
aujourd'hui ces puissances n avaient qu
avec les plateformes et ça ça me semble
important de noter pourquoi parce que
finalement ces plateformes sont des
intermédiaires et il en est de même pour
les donc qui génère des effets de réseau
et la valeur d'un réseau augmente avec
le nombre d'utilisateurs et c'est cette
mécanique l'a défait de réseaux croisé
qui conduit finalement arriver un effet
on a une tendance à une grande taille ou
les effets de réseau et les économies
d'échelle conduisent vraiment à ce qu'on
appelle en économie du numérique the
winner take all donc les plates formes
dominantes mettre en place des barrières
à l'entrée ça renforce la concentration
et toutes les études aujourd'hui
économique met en évidence que à la fois
la maîtrise des données et
l'optimisation fiscale va encore
renforcer la concentration alors si je
regarde plus en avant le modèle de
marché de la publicité puisque c'est lui
qui alimente la la mécanique est
finalement été au coeur de l'économie
des médias c'est vraiment ce marché à
deux versants avec le version publicité
si on regarde le marché de la publicité
aujourd'hui en ligne il pèse à peu près
6 milliards le marché le publicité des
médias c'est 14 milliards l'internet
c'est six mineurs via les plateformes
numériques en fait elle si fun pendant
l'expression les recettes publicitaires
des médias traditionnels qui eux sont
très peu présents sur le marché de la
publicité en ligne un marché je vous le
disais qu'ils passent 6 milliards était
dominé par trois acteurs google facebook
et est rejoint assez rapidement par par
amazon donc quand on dit dominé les
chiffres à peu près c'est entre 75 et
80% qui est concentré des
investissements publicitaires qui sont
concentrés en france sur ces deux
acteurs avec en plus amazon donc c'est
un marché qui est très complexe en vous
beaucoup d'intermédiaires techniques de
vente automatisés ça pénalise totalement
les acteurs traditionnels et là encore
ce qu'on dit c'est que les plateformes
numériques jouent le rôle de gatekeeper
donc deux points d'entrée qui oblige les
autres acteurs à passer et à utiliser
les outils très technique toujours
pareil des deux mêmes acteurs les google
et enfin et les gaffes façon façon
générale alors maintenant si je re
bascule sur le monde des médias mais
pour moi vous l'aurez compris les
plateformes numériques sont totalement
dans le monde des médias facebook c'est
plus de deux milliards et demi on
appelle d'utilisateurs tous les jours
dans le monde et on le dit et on dit que
c'est l'agora donc qui rentrent
considérer vraiment comme un gamin un
média de masse au sens au sens télé ou
radio
ce mouvement de concentration dans des
médias ont l'observent
aux états unis très largement ces
dernières années où ces deuxièmes moi en
tout cas on voit la multiplication des
opérations de fusions d'acquisitions
donc c'est un marché de façon générale
très concurrentiel dexter de cuzon plus
puissant je leur ai dit mais pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont des besoins importants
pour investir dans l'acquisition de
droits puissants touchèrent films séries
cinéma est une course et une inflation
dans cette acquisition de droits et dans
les prix évidemment dans la recherche et
développement dans l'innovation si vous
prend un seul un seul exemple en cinq
ans vous prenez la totalité des dépenses
en production audiovisuelle et
cinématographique du groupe tf1 m6
groupe canal+ et france télévisions ces
6 milliards d'euros c'est maintenant je
regarde un netflix les derniers chiffres
d'ici 2019 2020 17 milliards de dollars
en un an à lui tout seul je n'ai pas
pris en compte amazon je suis pas trop
content disney je n'ai pas pris en
compte tous ces acteurs qui quand on dit
surpuissant
moi-même même envie en tant qu'économie
c'est toujours très difficile donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle je la gagne
comme par exemple me semble me semble
assez assez importante et étonnante donc
beaucoup d'autres groupes européens
tentent en fait de jouer le rôle des
dés de l'europe des médias finalement
leur romance à à bertelsmann qui se
restructurent aura peut-être l'occasion
d'y penser à au groupe murdoch à
mediaset qui tendent aussi avoir une
position forte en europe et si on
regarde la france on voit bien que les
derniers mouvements participe de ce
mouvement de fusions d'acquisitions de
concentration tant côté vivendi blu ray
côté tf1 m6 ou le projet de fusion de
tf1 et m6 donc ça c'est si j'ose dire
pour l'année le décryptage par mois
ainsi de dire ainsi peut-être cela
influencerait kg pas suffisamment
insisté me semble-t-il c'est sûr mais on
y reviendra certainement c'est une fois
encore essayé sur le modèle économique
et sur le délai tout ça ils aiment
marquer parce que l'importante
l'importance dans ce dans ce modèle là
c'est qu'à la fois ça fonctionne sur la
publicité mais évidemment il ya autre
chose qui est très très fort c'est sur
les algorithmes et l'intelligence
artificielle ses délires sur la donner
mais il faut pas passer à côté de ce
point qui est qui et centrale donc à la
fois leur modèle c'est faciliter les
interactions ils sont l'aura compris
capté au maximum multiplier le nom de
services offerts gratuitement pour pour
collecter mais pour collecter toit de la
donner donc ce qu'on appelle toute
l'économie du big data avec
l'exploitation des algorithmes et de
l'intelligence artificielle qui sont
complètement constitutive de ce modèle
économique de marche à deux à deux
versants et on voit bien que c'est
toutes les traces que nous allons
laisser par par notre navigation sur des
millions de sites qui sont toujours
possédé par ces mêmes ces mêmes acteurs
et bien vont leur donner la possibilité
un de proposer de nouveaux services qui
va évidemment il on voit bien le winner
take all c'est à dire quelle commune
nous propose des nouveaux services
toujours accessible gratuitement avec
notre à cenon qui prouvent qu'ils
peuvent proposer de la publicité qui est
d'autant plus enrichie toujours par la
connaissance du profil qu'ils auront de
nous parce qu'on aura laissé des traces
l arbre on y reviendra avec ou sans
notre consentement paye des travaux
assez intéressant se ressourcer question
là et non que j'y viens maintenant et
c'est vraiment ce modèle là où à la fois
interactions et les collectes de la data
et son exploitation
l'impact sur la concentration sur la
démocratie on a clairement un espace
informationnel qui est de plus en plus
larges au risque d'être moins
démocratique les travaux du rapport
enfin les travaux et qu'on retrouve dans
le rapport stiegler qui s'avère siegler
committee en digital plateforme qui est
paru en 2019 qui est extrêmement riche
en la matière et la partie informe sur
la communication et les médias est
vraiment extrêmement intéressante il ya
des études économiques derrière et c'est
dans ce sens que l'analyse empirique et
est très riche où il nous montre bien
qu'on a une perturbation du marché
publicitaire puisque la demande de
l'imprimé c'est totalement déplacé vers
les sources médiatiques avis s'avère que
la presse a dû perdre en dix ans entre
50 à 70% de son de ses recettes en
france qu un publicitaire donc ça veut
dire qu'elle a vraiment son 100 m la
viabilité de son modèle économique et
est très très largement fragilisé
le danger démocratique c'est que les
plateformes diminue le pluralisme
augmente la concentration et qu'on
constate qu'on a un déclin du
journalisme local qui est due à
l'émergence justement de cette nouvelle
façon de s'informer et qui participe à
réduire la participation électorale et
changements dans les résultats
politiques c'est finalement là le retour
au départ que vous disiez sur sur
l'information aussi dans l'est les
travaux sur l'information quand même le
public en fait finalement des 54 ça
avait été bien mis en avant sur le fait
que l'information intrinsèquement qui
est contenu dans le média est un bien
public mais le support qui lui supporte
cette information pour partie était à
l'époque marchand donc c'est ce qui fait
que vous pouvez avoir un financement
aussi lecteurs abonnés aujourd'hui ce
support marchand et son enveloppe
finalement c'est complètement en partie
puisque bleus bien devient de nouveau
totalement public est intangible et dès
lors toutes les règles ils votaient de
ceux de ce marché de double versant
l'attendre la difficulté de je vais vous
demander de conclure ce qu'on arrive au
terme des dix minutes toute façon il y
aura dès qu'ils apprécieront
certainement de revenir sur les points
que vous avez abordé ou d'autres que
vous n'avez pas eu le temps de faire
pense que cette commission qui se réunit
aujourd'hui extrêmement importante elle
se réunit dans un contexte qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'urgence d'une
certaine manière il ya une mission qui a
été diligentée par la ministre la
douceur la ministre de l'économie sur
cette question de la concentration je
pense que c'est un complément
extrêmement nécessaire et peut-être un
peu tardif
parce que vu
les questions qui sont aujourd'hui sur
la table on peut craindre que les
conclusions de
cette mission de cette commission arrive
un peu trop tard pour venir résoudre des
problèmes qui sont extrêmement
importants donc la question qui se pose
portes sur la validité des dispositifs à
l'oeuvre aujourd'hui en france pour
éviter une concentration excessive dans
le secteur des médias en fait on a on a
une loi qui a évolué lentement depuis
1986 si je devais faire un peu un
parallèle que je regarde l évolution de
la loi de 1986 vu depuis 2000 21 je ne
dirais que c'est un peu comme si face à
l'introduction de l'électricité on avait
décidé d'aller dépoussiérer les
chandeliers donc on a une loi en fait
qui malgré les nombreux amendements qui
lui ont été apportés n'est plus du tout
adaptée au contexte actuel et on voit
très bien
aujourd'hui avec d'une part la fusion
qui est en train de se produire entre
tf1 et m6 et puis d'autre part lempire
où l'emprise grandissante de vivant dit
dans le secteur des médias si on prend
la loi de 1986 je dirais qu'elle qu'elle
prend l'eau un peu de toutes parts mais
au moins à trois endroits différents
donc il ya il ya différents dispositifs
dans la loi de 1986 pour commencer on a
on a ce qu'on appelle les dispositifs
mono médias donc sectorielle donc là des
dispositifs qui porte sur la
concentration dans le secteur de la
presse alors ils sont doublement
insuffisant ils sont insuffisants d'une
part parce qu'il ne porte que sur la
presse quotidienne d'information
politique et générale ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple si on a une
prise de contrôle qui est en train de de
sa mort c'est quand même si ça va c'est
encore sur le bureau de l'autorité de la
concurrence mais si on a une montée
qui accepte et au capital de vivendi de
lagardère média donc prise de contrôle
de paris match et d'une part du journal
du dimanche de l'autre vous avez deux
hebdomadaires dont on peut reconnaître
je pense l'importance pour le pluralisme
de la démocratie en france qui ne sont
pas du tout concernés par ce dispositif
anti-concentration puisque ce sont des
hebdomadaires et pas des quotidiens
d'information politique et générale on a
eu au début de l'année dernière la
validation par l'autorité de la
concurrence de la prise de contrôle de
vivendi sur le groupe prisma médias
c'est pareil prisma médias vous avez des
mensuels vous avez géo vous avez
capitale vous avez des hebdomadaires
vous avez vous aussi vous avez gala vous
en avez un certain
nombre d'autres et ni forcé mensuel ni
pour ses hebdomadaires la loi de 1986
s'applique puisqu'il ne s'agit pas de
quotidiens on reconnaîtra l'importance
politique du journal du dimanche je
pense qu'on reconnaîtra aussi une
importance politique en termes de débat
démocratique et de pluralisme d'un titre
comme le titre capital qui fait de
l'investigation économique donc déjà
indépendamment même de l'arrivée de
l'entrée du numérique d'une certaine
manière et cette fois en plus ne
concerne pas les sites internet
d'information on voit quelle pêche par
part çà çà çà çà définition extrêmement
étroites finalement de ce qui fait le
pluralisme de la presse qui est une
définition qu'on aurait pu déjà
interrogé en 1986 mais qui de toute
évidence aujourd'hui n'a plus aucune
validité d'autant que vous avez des
magazines des mensuels des demandeurs
des quotidiens qui rafraîchissent à peu
près à chaque minute voire secondes le
contenu de leur site internet donc ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose si on regarde l'aspect seulement
qui concerne la presse c'est que les
seuils de concentration sont définies en
pourcentages de la couverture du
territoire national
ce qui peut paraître légitime pour la
presse nationale ce qui est quand même
un peu plus problématique pour la presse
régionale notamment si l'on pense aux
quotidiens départementaux ou quotidiens
régionaux ce qui a permis la
concentration
enfin la constitution de monopoles
régionaux dans le secteur de la presse
quotidienne de la pqr et la pqd en
france et ça s'est accéléré au cours des
dernières années ça risque encore de
s'accélérer aujourd'hui puisque après la
prise de contrôle par angie presse du
groupe nice matin c'est à dire
nice-matin var-matin
monaco matin vous avez une jiji press
qui a déposé je crois aujourd'hui enfin
qui a fait connaître à l'autorité de la
concurrence sa volonté de prendre le
contrôle intégral du capital de la
provence donc voilà on voit que sur les
dispositifs presse même si on s'en tient
on n'est pas encore rentré dans le
numérique c'est hier qu'a la presse
écrite on a un certain nombre de
difficultés avec cette loi de 1986 sur
les dispositifs mono medien vous avez
aussi tout ce qui concerne la régulation
des seuils pour la télévision et la
radio et là ce qui est intéressant de
voir si cette définition d'un seuil à 49
% n'ont pas fait on s'est dit comment on
va on va limiter la concentration dans
dans le secteur de l'audiovisuel on
interdit finalement une entreprise ne
possédait plus de 49% du capital d'une
télévision privée qui aurait plus de 10
% de l'audience au niveau national
sauf qu'en fait on est passé
complètement à côté d'une notion qui me
paraît quand même essentiel qui est la
notion d' actionnaires de fig
majoritaire de fêtes ou d'actionnaire de
contrôle je pense que ici si je vous
interroge tous sur qui est l'actionnaire
de tf1 faisait tous me répondre bouygues
ne pas dire ça peut pas être le groupe
bouygues parce que bouygues à moins de
50% du capital de tf1 est ce assez c'est
extrêmement intéressant parce que je
pense que en termes de réponses à
apporter une manière de modifier la loi
de 1986 on voit que 49% ça ne suffit pas
mais que si on dit que 40%
ça ne suffira peut-être pas davantage et
donc il faut réussir à penser la notion
d'actionnaire majoritaire de fait il
faut réussir à penser l'introduction
finalement de règles qui limitent les
droits de vote et le pouvoir de contrôle
d'un actionnaire qui de fait se retrouve
majoritaire ou en tout cas si c'est là
la volonté
derrière ce que stipule la régulation en
tout cas si la volonté était de ne pas
permettre à un actionnaire de posséder
plus de la moitié du capital de fait si
vous avez entièrement le contrôle en
termes de pluralisme de l'information on
voit que la disposition est relativement
inopérantes
ensuite vous avez du coup un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui sont des
dispositifs qui porte sur enfin
plurimédia et notamment ce qu'on appelle
la fameuse règle du deux sur trois je ne
pouvais qu'une disposition radio une
disposition télé une disposition presse
écrite qui souffre d'ailleurs pour la
presse écrite du même problème que la
disposition presse mono médias et là on
voit aussi toute la difficulté puisque
le numérique n'a pas du tout été
introduit dans la réflexion par rapport
à la loi de 1986
ce qui s'est passé quand je dis qu'elle
prend l'eau de toute part d'une certaine
manière je je je pense fondamentalement
que
cette loi n'est pas seulement amender
elle est à réécrire
à zéro en fait pour toutes ces raisons
et puis pour d'horizon
supplémentaires d'une part c'est que sur
la régulation de l'audiovisuel notamment
de la télé il ya que des anciens qui est
pris en compte dans cette loi puis
d'autre part le fait que safran
aujourd'hui en compte le problème de
concentration notamment au niveau
horizontal mais pas du tout les
problèmes de concentration au niveau
verticale
du coup on a vu pourquoi avec l'exemple
de la presse ça ne s'était pas appliqué
à
la constitution d'un empire médiatique
par le groupe vivendi et après se pose
la question je pense dans l'actualité
immédiate de la fusion entre tf1 et m6
et ce qui pose une troisième difficulté
avec la régulation actuelle qui fait
qu'on a deux autorités indépendantes qui
ont à se prononcer sur sur cette fusion
mais qui finalement un cahier des
charges extrêmement différents d'une
part la question de l'autorité de la
concurrence et d'autre part la question
du alors je sais pas s'il faut qu'on
dise encore c'est ça jusqu'au 31
décembre comme quand je veux dire c'est
sa part par facilité la question du csa
qui doit se prononcer sur
sur le point du pluralisme et j'en
arrive aussi du coup à
la question des arguments qui sont
autorisés aujourd'hui
utilisée aujourd'hui en faveur de cette
fusion je pas vous apparaître comme une
espèce d'extra terrestres qui seraient
passés complètement à côté de l'histoire
et notamment à côté de l'arrivée de la
fin et à côté de l'arrivée des grandes
plateformes de vod que ce soit netflix
que ce soit les autres je suis tout à
fait consciente du fait que le paysage
médiatique a énormément changé qu'il a
énormément changé au cours des dernières
années et que ça appelle à interroger la
loi de 1986 et d'ailleurs je pense que
de ce point de vue là on fait tous ceux
qui qui sont pour par exemple la fusion
tf1 m6 ou contre la fusion tf1 et m6
sont d'accord sur le fait que la loi de
1986 est inopérante sauf que d'un côté
vous avez une problématique qui une
problématique purement économique et
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a pense en termes
de constitution de géants et notamment
la constitution de géants nationaux
voire de géant de l'audiovisuel européen
et d'un autre côté vous avez une
problématique qui est problématique en
termes de pluralisme est ce qui est
relativement étonnant je pense
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on soit prêt
finalement
au nom de la concentration économique
qui devrait nous interroger en termes
d'information mais également en termes
de création audiovisuelle en termes de
production qui devraient nous interroger
sur la menace que font peser les gaffes
à les plateformes de vidéo à la demande
sur
le pluralisme de l'information des
contenus qui sont offerts aux
consommateurs on est pris finalement à
sacrifier le peu de fou le réalisme qui
nous reste pour résoudre une
problématique de surconcentration par la
constitution de nouveaux monopoles
et c'est ça qui me semble tout à fait
paradoxal je suis sûr vous aurez des
questions sur ce point je vais je vais
vous interrompre lui donner la parole à
notre rapporteur pour une série de
questions précises
seulement voilà oui je mon jour est
vraiment très très heureux que vous ayez
répondu à notre invitation à venir nous
éclairer car le muet et bien été de nous
éclairer à travers nous éclairer le
débat public sur cet enjeu
de la concentration des médias bhl je
vous propose que
un mode de
questionnements et de réponse
le plus le plus
interactive possible et précis c'est à
dire que on va commencer par le madame
sonnac je vous pose une question gens
posent pas trois vous répondez gens
posent une autre vous répondez comme ça
on a des réponses précises parce que
sinon on va repartir sur des
explications qui qui auront mots notre
activité alors
dans une tribune que vous avez publiée
dans le monde le 20 novembre dernier
vous avez comme vous l'avez fait la
élargi la question de la concentration
des médias
dans une direction qui le faut bien
entendu
regardez en insistant sur les risques
que font peser les gaffes à sur les
médias en asséchant les ressources
publicitaires
ce qui pour vous les pousse à la
concentration
eux mêmes et que donc c'est sous la
pression aux fêtes et les plateformes
que le mouvement de concentration qui
peut exister en france
tf1 m6 par exemple ou d'autres
concentrations dans la presse et caetera
existait ce que vous
j'ai envie de vous poser la question est
ce que vous pensez
que
le paysage tel qu'il est aujourd'hui est
trop ou pas assez concentré
merci pour votre question
le paysage médiatique tel que je
l'entends
il est constitué à la fois les
télévisions des radios
de l'affichage du cinéma de la presse
écrite évidemment et puis de l'ensemble
des sites sur internet qui sont
accessibles sur les sites sur internet
de façon générale il y à la fois le
prolongement de ces mêmes titres que
l'on connaît je la déclinaison de
l'ensemble des médias et puis évidemment
une myriade d'autres titres par exemple
médias parce n'existe pas en version
papier il est accessible moyennant
finances
on se sent sous abonnement donc est ce
que le la question de la concentration
il me semble que et les propos de julia
cagé sur uniquement sur internet sur la
partie de la mesure fait que je vois que
le mouvement de concentration existe
c'est-à-dire à que de plus en plus en
tout cas que des médias
divers et variés appartiennent ou sont
dans le giro l'urne d'un seul et même
groupe donc un groupe comme
effectivement bolloré ou primes
bertelsmann prisma murdoch et ses
différentes entités donc à nu plurimédia
et qui fait qu'on voit bien aujourd'hui
que la mesure n'est pas du tout il doit
non donc vous dire que je trouve que
c'est concentré où vous répondre à la
question je trouve que ça ne l'est pas
je vois bien que il y à un billet pas
dans votre question
mais enfin peut-être mais en tout cas
dans ma réponse elle l'aurait on n'a pas
un instrument de mesure si maintenant
vous me dites il veut me permet de
prolonger que l'information politique et
générale le pluralisme de la presse le
pluralisme de l'information pardon élus
et concentrés là on peut déjà aller plus
regardée plus mesuré non pas avec les
instruments de la m 86 kg effectivement
pour cela ne sont ne sont pas n'est pas
la bonne focale et c'est d'autant pas la
bonne photo cannes c'est qu'elles ne
mesurent pas ce qu'elle doit mesurer
c'est si vous me permettez dans l'inde
et dans le rapport justement de stieg
l'air on voit qui est un auteur qui
s'appelle andrea printemps qui basent
sur les parts d'attention et avec les
part d'attention aucun indice de mesure
de concentration aujourd'hui qu'ils
seraient les part d'attention à savoir
un niveau individuel sur le pourcentage
du temps qu'un individu va consacrer à
une source médiatique
/ temps total qui va consacrer à
l'ensemble des sources et là on verrait
dans l'ensemble des sources ci s'est
concentré ou pas moi vous dire que un
disney participons empêche le pluralisme
de l'information je réponds pas est-ce
que ça un secteur qui est extrêmement
puissant est ce que c'est un acteur qui
danse chant informationnelle et
communicationnel et extrêmement
puissants oui
deuxième question précise
coderre
là
l'argument qui est souvent évoqué
pour justifier aujourd'hui dans le
paysage tel qu'il est des concentrations
des fusions des regroupements c'est que
c'est
inévitable si on veut justement résister
à une concurrence des grandes
plateformes américaines vous avez
éclairer un peu de quoi il s'agit vous
dites qu'en six ans 150
tf1 canal et m6 et 6 milliards france
télévisions de chez france télévisions
celles et leurs goûts et tous les
acteurs dont vanessa fin horrible ce
sera encore plus à mon sens donc en cinq
ans et ça et en un an seulement elle
fixe et 17 milliards c'est ça que vous
avez dit
même si oui voilà donc on est dans
presque 17 fois plus sur un seul acteur
du numérique par rapport à tout le monde
aux usa dont je vous demande si vous
considérez que la façon de résister à
ces plateformes c'est par la
concentration et la fusion et la
rassemblement des forces capitalistique
et de possibilités d'investissement
qu'il qui peut être au perron peut
croire que la constitution ne sont
utiles que de grands groupes industriels
européens française donc et médiatique
qu'est la concentration industrielle de
ces grands groupes européens est
indispensable et dans le même temps il
me semble que dans ce champ là qui est
extrêmement large qui est celui de
l'information de la communication qui
est mélangé
tf1 investi dans l'information embauche
les journalistes dans le même temps ils
achètent
des programmes il fabrique de la fiction
qu'on voit bien que c'est un groupe qui
dans le sens de l'information pour
mettre tout ça en même temps mais c'est
pas en même temps donc il me semble que
la focale et les plus ils plus étroite
que celle ci oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui
les grands groupes industriels
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours pensé était
nécessaire dans le monde des médias
maintenant il me semble qu est ce qui
est extrêmement important que pour
garantir le pluralisme il faut que très
vite nous trouvions des outils
nécessaires et il me semble que la loi
et mes six années au csa avec
l'application afrikaner de 86 qui
garantit la liberté de communication
effectivement est indispensable et
qu'aujourd'hui la réglementation et la
loi sont indispensables pour protéger
les entreprises culturelles et ainsi par
exemple des romains qui pourraient y
participer outre le fait d'utiliser un
nouvel indice est qu'il ya des auteurs
qui ont trouvé on pas dire c'est l'alpha
l'eau mais la météo on trouvait ça
serait de mettre des on a bien de 6,2
d'aller chercher là où ça fait mal
c'est-à-dire son marché de publicité on
a bien su avec la loi de la
réglementation de protéger les
entreprises culturelles en protégeant le
secteur du cinéma en interdisant le jour
interdit pendant très longtemps très
longtemps les jours c'est un certains
secteurs étaient interdits de publicité
à la télévision en vertu en raison de
protéger le cinéma pourquoi aujourd'hui
ou n'attaquerait pas sur le modèle du
marché publicitaire le fait que lui on
obligerait les annonceurs a dit si fier
leurs achats d'espacés publicitaires
dans des médias c'est à dire que hal
voilà à développer mais jouer pour
conclure dans mes questions à vous et je
le répèterai pas ça peut vous introduire
parce que je vous la poser à vous trois
il ya une particularité que vous n'avez
pas souligner nos exposés mais je sais
vous le connaissez c'est que les grands
groupes français
ne se sont en général pas constitué
par intérêt ou par objet social
fondateur la presse où l'information ou
le média
vivendi s'est pas son objet social on va
dire
mais pas en afrique et ça peut changer
avant c'était autre chose et c'est
ben oui c'est le btp puis je peux
continuer comme ça c'est bien ça le
coeur de leur métier donc ma question
que je pose aux 3 c'est à votre avis
pourquoi
des
industriels
fondateurs d'entreprise capitaines
d'industrie parfois grands financiers
par exemple les banques et assurances
qui contrôlent quasiment toute la presse
pqr dans le pays
pour de l'intérêt en posséder les médias
parce qu apparemment ça ne rapporte pas
autant que le reste donc six jeux
bon ou peut-être pas en tous les cas je
pose vraiment la question donc avoué
ensuite ça peut vous introduire
en 3 réponse est oui on commence parti
même kg est toute la question est de
savoir si si vous parlez de rentabilité
directe ou de rentabilité indirectes
c'est-à-dire que le retour sur
investissement dans le secteur des
médias n'est n'est pas toujours aussi
important que dans un certain nombre
d'autres secteurs d'activité quoique
je crois me souvenir par exemple sur le
cas de m6 comme de tf1 qu' on a deux
groupes qui ont très bien surmonté la
crise de l'aco vides y compris en termes
de parts de marché publicitaires etc on
a un marché publicitaire qui se porte
d'ailleurs régis samson nous ont plutôt
bien en france les pays voire de la
rentabilité y compris dans le secteur
des médias ensuite si on interroge des
motivations profondes ça va forcément
varier d'un acteur à un autre on peut
pas faire de généralités
c'est une manière d'obtenir de l'axé ça
ça a été extrêmement bien documenté et
quand vous êtes dans des secteurs aussi
sensibles par exemple que le secteur des
télécoms où vous avez toute une
problématique de régulation qui est
extrêmement importante le fait d'avoir
accès notamment aux hommes et aux femmes
politiques est loin d'être quelque chose
de négligeable ça peut donner du pouvoir
politique
directe ou indirecte
vous avez mentionné foxnews rupert
murdoch ne s'est jamais caché de
financer à la fois d'ailleurs il a
financé des conservateurs au royaume uni
comme la république un aux états unis
directement et indirectement finalement
avec sa chaîne fox news on a parlé de
vincent bolloré bon on sait tous
aujourd'hui qu'on a une certaine
déclaration de candidature vous avez
aussi un intérêt à investir dans le
secteur médiatique pour pousser un
agenda politique donc c'est difficile
d'avoir une vision globale parce que
forcément ça va pas on peut prendre
différents acteurs qui sont motivés par
différents facteurs mais ce qu'on voit
de manière répétée c'est que le facteur
de l' influence économique c'est à dire
l'impact sur la régulation on pourrait
citer aussi jeff bezos le patron
d'amazon quand il rachète le washington
post c'est un peu un paria à l'époque ou
rh et au washington post ça ouvre les
portes et quand vous êtes dans le
e-commerce ouvrir les portes du
régulateur c'est pas quelque chose qui
est négligeable voilà ça veut pas dire
que ça s'applique à chacun certains ont
de meilleurs motivation sans doute que
d'autres mais ça veut dire qu'on a
laissé cette possibilité puisque vous
avez mentionné oui je pense qu'il est
aussi important de souligner que vous
avez un certain nombre de pays on aurait
pu aussi
mentionné le figaro et dassault où il
n'est pas autorisé d'être actionnaire
majoritaire d'un média et d'avoir des
contrats avec la puissance publique ce
qui n'est pas le cas en france est ce qu
on pourrait légitimement interrogé
également
bien compris c'est pourquoi en france ce
sont des capitaines d'industrie qui
intérieur qui investissent à la marge ou
après avoir fait fortune dans d'autres
dans d'autres métiers dans le secteur
des médias c'est bien ça oui enfin pas
seulement des capitaines d'industrie les
jo qui dont le métier dont l'activité
principale activité originelle neuvien
ne vient pas des médias
je je je pense qu'il ya une tradition
[Musique]
française de du rôle très important de
l'état dans l'activité économique
industriel et en particulier de
l'utilisation de la de la commande
publique
singulièrement soula sous la vème
république
pour fabriquer des champions nationaux
industriel
leu leu
ne s'est pas véritablement un hasard si
marcel dassault qui a monté son son
entreprise assez largement sur le
développement de
l'équipement militaire
a cherché à avoir une une activité dans
la presse pour conforter son son
influence auprès de son donneur d'ordre
je pense que pour ce qui est de l'entrée
de lagardère initialement dans le dans
le secteur il y avait des préoccupations
de même nature quand on quand on voit
ensuite la manière dont s'est constitué
le secteur audiovisuel et singulièrement
la télévision on voit que le général de
gaulle avait voulu que ce fut un
monopole d'état précisément pour contrer
le pouvoir politique de la presse qui
était plus diversifiée et indépendante
et quand il s'est agi d'ouvrir
le le monopole d'état à l'entrée de
nouveaux acteurs le président mitterrand
qui a initié la démarche a choisi celui
qui devait devenir son exécuteur
testamentaire pour lui confier la
première concession de télévision privée
qui fait très original en france était
une
concession de télévision payante alors
que tous les autres pays du monde ont
libéralisé là en fin ou la télévision
était originellement une
activité
étatique long libéralisé par la
télévision gratuite donc
systématiquement si vous voulez les
les médias on était dans le coin dans le
régime de la télévision
concédé
contre obligations à des amis du pouvoir
le
est qui qui étaient des industriels
puissants dans le temps dans le pays et
au fur et à mesure que ce le le paysage
s'est complexifié et diversifiée avec
l'apparition de technologies nouvelles
le
l'organisation industrielle s'est s'est
elle aussi développée suivant ces
conditions initiales si je puis dire
mercenac
peut-être en quelques mots parce que
effectivement je pense qu'effectivement
le concept d' influence économique et
politique je serai en revanche je ne
voudrais pas celle de notoriété publique
indépendante
non c'était une piste parce que je pense
qu'il ya une interaction et c'est parce
que c'est en tout cas la question de
l'accessibilité à des telles qu ou avec
des d autorité indépendante de
régulation je n'ai pas ce sentiment des
changes particuliers ou privilégiés avec
une autorité de régulation en
particulier en tout cas pour celles que
je connais et je dirais que sur celle ci
en revanche effectivement pour répondre
plus directement
oui vous voyez bien qu'il y a cette
volonté en tout cas cette possibilité
qui est offerte parce qu'elle est de
disposer de deux journaux et donc d'
influence souhaite économique une fois
encore par le biais aussi d'annonceurs
publicitaires ça y participent cette
influence économique 1 c et puis
évidemment politique et je crois que
dieu l a rappelé l'histoire ce qu'elle
tourne tout son temps moi j'aurais eu
une question qui s'adresse aux anneaux
trois invités du jour
[Musique]
on est sur un écosystème vous venez de
le dire des médias extrêmement puissant
et qui est en pleine en pleine mutation
alors pour tenter de de réguler cet
écosystème nous sommes nous en france
avec à disposition des instruments
antique qui sont un peu la naphtaline ou
qui sont une complexité énorme et avec
lesquels se régale que ce soit les
industriels que ce soit les les juristes
pour contourner les sujets d'abord et
vous l'avez dit chère madame les lois de
86 qui sont totalement poussiéreuse et
donc encore sur ce quinquennat nous ne
l'état n'a pas souhaité puisque on était
à deux doigts d'aboutir quand même sur
quelque chose qui n'aurait pas été
forcément idéal mais qui aurait eu le
mérite justement quand même d'avancer ça
n'a pas été possible nous avons aussi
une juxtaposition de règles de droit
commun absolument hallucinante où on
assiste à une partie de ping pong entre
l'autorité de la concurrence et le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel nous
avons et alors là ça ne dérange personne
ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure par
nathalie sonnac mais une concentration
verticale qui ne dérange personne là on
parle même on vient pas nous parler de
concentration mais c'est à l'oeuvre tous
les jours et nous avons notre sacro
saint principe du pluralisme qui fait
que pour la presse écrite si je
comprends bien la presse d'opinion est
tout à fait possible pour encourager
tolérée elle est même financé par l'état
par de l'argent public
en revanche pour les services d'édition
télévisuel c'est interdit
parce que la diffusion hertzienne
se fait ou en tout cas c'est critiquer
parce que la diffusion hertzienne et
parce que c'est une diffusion hertzienne
et monsieur bien monsieur bomsel pardon
excusez moi vient de le rappeler c'est
l'état qui délivre les autorisations
et donc à partir de ce moment là et dans
le cadre de l'écriture d'une nouvelle
loi est-ce que vous pensez que la
télévision ne pourraient pas suivre le
chemin de la presse
qui veut répondre n'êtes pas obligé de
répondre tous les trois qui si vous le
souhaitez par contre n'hésitez pas
ce que madame kg
pour elle à redéfinir en disant est ce
que aujourd'hui pour la télévision il
faut garantir le pluralisme de manière
interne est-ce qu'il faut garantir le
pluralisme de manière externe voilà
pourquoi on s'est pas posé la question
pour la pour la presse écrite parce que
pour la presse écrite les coûts d'entrée
sont relativement faibles il l'était
déjà à l'époque du papier le sont encore
davantage aujourd'hui et ce qui nous
permet finalement d'avoir un éventail
d'opinions qui sont représentés
aujourd'hui pour la presse écrite et
quand vous allez finalement dans les
kiosques aussi parce qu'on aime une
régulation dès 1947 avec la loi bichet
qui a favorisé finalement l'entrée et la
survie de petits journaux vous pouvez
trouver des journaux de toute opinion
c'est extrêmement différent pour la
télévision pour deux raisons 1 parce que
on a quand même nombre de fréquences
suffit de regarder la tnt qui est réduit
et je pense que ceux qui disent que ça
ne tient plus aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
la télévision numérique or des nouvelles
chaînes de télé vient par exemple blast
se tromper il se trompe parce qu'en
termes d'audience on parle pas du tout
des mêmes chiffres oui à des chaînes de
télévision aujourd'hui sur sur internet
mais ça touche une audience extrêmement
réduite d'ailleurs ça touche une
audience extrêmement jeunes qui ne
votent pas si vous regardez la
population qui se déplace aujourd'hui
aux urnes c'est la population qui
regardent majoritairement la tnt donc la
première chose si vous avez un certain
nombre de chaînes et que ce nombre là il
est réduit donc fait pas ancrée advitam
eternam à l'infini pour couvrir le
spectre politique deuxième chose et ça
peut paraître étonnant mais c'est
documenté c'est comme ça
les gens allument leur télé il a pu
chaîne par chaîne 1 2 3 4 5 delphine
ernotte était la première à lierre
d'ailleurs quand elle expliquer la perte
d'un demi voire un point d'audience de
france infos tv par rapport aux autres
chaînes d'information en continu
notamment ces news et bfm tv par sa
numérotation donc en fait c'est un enjeu
être numéro 15 au numéro 16 ça paraît
étonnant vous fouillez allumez votre
télé sur les 950 si ça vous prend pas
beaucoup plus de temps que de la lumi
sur l'armée des gens font pas et c'est
la réalité aujourd'hui donc on peut
déplorer les comportements de
consommation mais c'est comme ça que les
gens consomment la télévision ce qui
fait que
en objet de garantir un pluralisme
interne des chaînes parce qu'on sait pas
faire sur du pluralisme externe c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas
garantir sur la tnt que vous allez avoir
sur la une chaîne de télévision marqué à
droite et puis sur la deux pour
compenser une chaîne de télévision
marqué à gauche sur la trop 3 plutôt
centriste et sur la trans et pas faire
et on saura pas le faire
technologiquement rapidement ça veut
dire que dans vingt ou vingt-cinq ans
peut-être même dans 5 ou 10 ans quoique
c'est un con ça ça ça m'étonnerait pas
ce que je consomme comportements de
consommation sont lents a évolué on ne
sera pas capable de le faire aujourd'hui
on sait pas le faire et sauf que je
pense que ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir un cadre qui
garantissent le pluralisme dans les
conditions actuelles de consommation de
médias et donc de fonctionnement de la
démocratie ensuite un dernier petit
point et je m'arrête là dessus
on essaie
de préserver le pluralisme interne pour
les chaînes de télévision ça veut pas
dire qu'on va aussi
et là pour le coup à la fois
l'utilisation de ces pouvoirs que fait
le csa et les pouvoirs qui sont entre
les mains du csa mérite d'être
questionnée aujourd'hui ça a été le cas
on l'a vu au tour de la question de ces
news notamment le fait de ne régule et
que le temps de parole des personnalités
politiques en fait on voit que ça peut
permettre à des chaînes finalement
d'arrêter d'inviter des personnalités
politiques de ne mettre que des
chroniqueurs à l'antenne qui ont à
propos tout aussi voire plus politique
que les personnalités politiques et là
c'est sans même parler des rediffusions
à l'infini des discours chose pour le
coc et yannick jadot toute la nuit pour
satisfaire aux obligations de floralis
mme donc sauf le réalisme interne on est
censé attendre par la loi mais ça veut
pas dire qu'aujourd'hui se réguler de
manière satisfaisante j'ai une piste qui
n'a pas été évoquée face à la crise des
différents médias et d'énormes besoins
d'investissement qui sont devant quel
qu'il soit que ce soit la presse écrite
ou la presse audiovisuelle et face aux
gars femme est ce que la piste une
réinvention de modèle coopératif
immédiat n'est pas plus pertinente pour
faire face à l'enjeu démocratique celle
de la concentration des médias qui
évidemment pose des problèmes nos
tensions évidentes avec l'enjeu du
pluralisme et de la démocratie
par exemple dans la presse écrite il y
avait beaucoup plus de titres avant
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire à la libération mais on
oublie de dire qu'ils avaient des
systèmes coopératifs très puissant
système de distribution system l'achat
du papier il y avait une agence france
presse qui jouait d'une certaine manière
un rôle coopératifs en matière de
recherche de l'information et d'autres
choses aujourd'hui même dans
l'audiovisuel j'entends le service
public faire des propositions de
coopération
à ses partenaires privés je ne suis pas
sûr que la concentration tf1 m6
on s'oriente vers une réponse positive
aux offres de coopération du service
public fait par le service public on
maintient audiovisuel mais est ce que
cette piste coopérative
réinventer dans les conditions
aujourd'hui et pour faire face aux
enjeux actuels ne seraient pas plus
pertinente que la piste de la
concentration pour
concilier
les enjeux des nouveaux besoins et celle
de des enjeux du pluralisme et de la
démocratie
line renaud garabédian
merci de toutes vos réponses à la
question je serais plutôt vous la posez
avoue julia cagé vous avez tous les
trois mentionné le fait que les réseaux
sociaux jouer un rôle déterminant
aujourd'hui dans l'accès à l'information
surtout en particulier pour les plus
jeunes pouvez vous revenir s'il vous
plaît sur la manière dont cela va
bouleverser les grands groupes
médiatiques sachant qu'ils ont une
capacité plus importante sur ses plates
formes puisque les médias indépendants
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup plus de moyens
que les médias indépendants or il s'agit
là d'une publicité qui n'est pas régulé
ce que l'on regrette d'ailleurs
contrairement à ce qui concerne la
promotion politique
merci de vos réponses comment on
fabrique l'information il ya un mot
qu'on a très peu utilisé ici depuis le
début de
cette réunion
c'est le mot de journalistes
le problème c'est pas qu'on ait moins de
lecteurs aujourd'hui en fait on a pas
moins de gens qui consomment de
l'information il ne la consomme sur des
supports différents je pense qu'il faut
se désintéresser complètement de la
question du support
presse écrite numérique télévision radio
ces supports entièrement fusionner vous
allez aujourd'hui sur les sites internet
d'européens de france télévisions vous
avez des sites qui sont en concurrence
directe avec le site du monde ou du
figaro je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
les débats qui avaient eu au moment où
il y avait eu un accord entre france 24
et mâcha me sur le fait qu'on allait
finalement financer avec de l'argent
public un concurrent d des sites
d'information politique et générale est
en fait la réponse à ça et réveillons
nous ça fait quand même depuis longtemps
en fait que le site de france info par
exemple concurrence directement mais en
terme d'audience ans et en terme de
contenu on pourrait faire un jeu et
c'est à dire projetées sur un écran
aujourd'hui les pages d'accueil en
effaçant tous les loulous
de europe 1 de france télévisions de
france inter du monde de libération en
fait je suis pas sûr que vous retrouviez
le support hors ligne donc il faut
effacer cette question du support ça
c'est vraiment là la première chose faut
qu'on arrive à l'effacer ensuite il faut
qu'on ait conscience du fait qu'on peut
pas faire d'information sans
journalistes et là je suis pas d'accord
avec le fait qu'il n'y avait jamais eu
autant d'informations aujourd'hui
l'information elles circulent mais c'est
pas le cas de la production
d'information original veulent une
information
copier-coller très souvent qui circule
en boucle et ce dont on a besoin en est
mocratie c'est pas d'une information
copier coller qui circule en boucle
c'est d'information original et ce qui
devrait vraiment nous inquiéter je pense
en premier lieu c'est quand on regarde
les chiffres de la carte de presse même
si je sais qu'il peut y avoir des débats
sur la définition d'un journaliste
professionnel etc etc on peut toujours
dire qu'il ya un certain nombre de
journalistes qui n'ont pas la carte de
presse je suis d'accord avec ça sauf
qu'en termes de tendance la disparition
et la baisse tendancielle du nombre de
journalistes qu'on mesure notamment très
bien avec la carte de presse
ça nous montre le fait qu'on a moins de
production d'information original et ça
ça devrait tous nous inquiéter puisque
pierre laurent a mentionné tout à
l'heure le cas de l' agence
france-presse les effectifs de l' agence
france-presse au cours des dernières
années se sont réduits pourquoi les
effectifs de l' agence france presse se
sont réduits en particulier parce que
parmi les premiers clients de l' agence
france-presse même si c'est en train de
changer aujourd'hui de modèle économique
et de s'internationaliser et de défendre
également d'ailleurs de plus en plus des
des plateformes
vous avez les médias français vous avez
des médias qui s'appauvrissent donc ils
vont payer des abonnements de moins en
moins chers donc moindre ressource
finalement pour cette coopérative entre
guillemets qui vient nous alimenter en
informations originales et c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut extrêmement
s'inquiéter la question des réseaux
sociaux pour pour moi c'est exactement
la même que celle des plateformes vous
avez des réseaux sociaux comme des
plateformes qui aujourd'hui tirent une
partie non négligeable de leurs contenus
pendant une partie non négligeable de
leurs revenus de contenus qu'ils ne
produisent pas et qu'il ne paie pas pour
produire et en fait bon il ya des
avancées qui ont été faites avec le
droit voisin et tant mieux on peux les
saluer elles sont complètement
insuffisante notamment si on met dans la
balance les pertes qui ont été infligés
aux médias traditionnels par la
concurrence de ces plateformes versus
que ces plateformes sont aujourd'hui
prêtes alors payer mais on a un
véritable problème de modèle économique
à la fois des plateformes et des réseaux
sociaux indépendamment même de la
question des fêtes news et ensuite on a
ce problème qui est doublé par le fait
que vous avez des réseaux sociaux qui ne
tirent leurs revenus que de la publicité
qu'on sait que les fausses d'information
sont génératrices de davantage de clics
donc elles ont une incitation financière
directe a favorisé la propagation de ces
faisait informations par rapport à des
contenus plus ennuyeux entre guillemets
mais plus informatif en termes de en
termes de démocratie mais du coup je
veux juste finir par par là dire d'une
certaine manière que je pense qu'il faut
pas il faut avoir conscience de toutes
les contraintes que font peser
aujourd'hui la concurrence des
plateformes internationales ça c'est
certain
en même temps on peuvent à partir
de ce point là
pour réguler la concentration des médias
en france parce que sinon on aura
l'impression d'être toujours face à un
mur faire qu'on va partir du principe
pour dix rames et finalement face à
netflix on n'aura finalement jamais
assez de concentration donc il faut
revenir finalement au point de départ de
1986 à l'objectif constitutionnel du
pluralisme
penser les règles qui permettent
aujourd'hui de garantir le pluralisme
encore une fois je pense qu'il faut pas
amender cette loi il faut réécrire une
loi notamment en effaçant complètement
la question des supports et
indépendamment de ça il faut pas
s'interdire faut au contraire et il
faudrait s'attaquer à la régulation des
plateformes à la régulation des réseaux
sociaux à la régulation de ces monopoles
qui je pense ne pourra être fait pour le
coup qu'au niveau européen mais il faut
réussir à attaquer les deux problèmes de
front parce que j'ai l'impression pour
l'instant la montagne gaffe a finalement
parlé si effrayante bac on ne
s'interroge pas sur tout le reste du
problème est encore une fois les
chiffres que tu donnes et nathalie sur
la consommation de réseaux sociaux c'est
vrai chez les 18 24 ans mais c'est pas
la population qui vote on peut aussi
s'en
lamenter d'ailleurs l'un n'est pas sans
lien direct avec l'autre mais la
population qui vote massivement encore
aujourd'hui c'est la population qui
consomment massivement de l'audiovisuel
sur sa télé de manière traditionnelle en
zappant d'une chaîne à l'autre et on
peut pas sauter par-dessus 30 ans de vie
démocratique en régulant directement une
consommation de visuels qui serait
complètement délinéarisée et numérique
[Musique]